professor ramalingam teleport now he is
one of the biggest names and signal
processing that I know which may be
either my ignorant Tsar the truth
whatever weights it's fine right he's a
native of Chennai
I think it did his PhD at Purdue some
many years ago yeah you did you finished
your PhD just when I started my PhD
actually that's good then I have six or
seven years on you
he's been at Maryland practically ever
since right oh you were abused USC USC
well he was at USC for a couple of years
and then drama and drama drama dn't get
along so rama decided to move to no but
since then you know he's worked on
actually a number of fields he's sort of
originally what you might call the
traditional signal processing image
processing background but he's been one
of the leaders in computer division in
multiple areas in motion analysis image
registration compression he's a fellow
of most of the known organizations I
Triple E I a PR various other things and
what else I just found out that back in
the seventy five he got a hundred and
twenty five dollar price for something
from the old boys Association of Ginty
Engineering College this is the most
interesting fact about of that I know
you have to explain during your talk
what that is okay thanks well honor than
always likes to pull my legs hands head
mean whatever he can pull he tries to do
that from one Chennai to the other
tonight that's how we greet each other
and I'm happy to be here and so today I
want to talk about compressive sensing
and sparse representations compressive
sensing is is an area that's again
gaining lot of interest maybe over the
last five years or so mostly due to some
really wonderful work done by
mathematicians and statisticians Prosser
Donahoe Candace at Caltech Towell UCLA
and so forth and and it has a lot of
interesting applications of course you
know across all
Effects of signal processing hyper
spectral processing infrared processing
regular video spectrum speech and so
forth so it's something that is what
knowing about you know and also since it
is based on nice mathematics we can
actually build on it
you know I am a professor in engineering
and I have an affiliate position in
computer science I'm an applied person
I'd like to understand as much as
possible what mathematicians and
statisticians and businesses have done
and see if some of those techniques can
be used and but if and also if you are
have a background in signal processing
you will appreciate this a little bit
more and of course there's my one of my
mentors Prosser Tom Wayne used to say
there is nothing new Under the Sun and I
have been in computer vision since the
mid 80s I started my thesis was on
Markov random fields 1981 I finished at
Purdue and I learned at that time the
funding engines we wanted to fund only
statisticians in MRX and not professors
in EE so I said what is the next best
thing to do i moved to computer vision
okay so but the point in this slide is
that things look like new but they're
kind of not new many of these things
have come again and again for example
Arabs are making a big comeback in
graphics and in the context of inference
and graphical models and so on and
regularization is now back again in the
compressive sensing world it's called
the basis Pursuit denoising and and all
that stuff is all basically
regularization and invariants were
present on binford made some fundamental
contributions to that and it goes away
and comes back goes away and comes back
in the 80s and so on it was the object
recognition now people want to do it for
action recognition can you develop view
and variate action recognition so and
likewise you know particle filters and
so on right so a computational sensing
started in the 90s and then particular
envision well you know like now
everybody is like MATLAB routine now you
know you don't have to really know F of
T is there you call MATLAB F of T does
it worry you don't have to understand
the beautiful butterfly diagram
and all of that which if you take a
course in DSP you have to understand
there go through Oppenheimer and
Schaffer I did that in 1976
so now folks who have not even done a
course in random process are estimation
Theory happily apply particle filters
for their problem you know so that's
what I'm saying so it has become like a
50 in DSP you can just apply particle
filter just go to matlab okay so anyway
some manifolds and so forth so what I'm
saying is these are many things that
have kind of come so when you hear
compressive sensing and somebody's very
excited about it
you want to ask the question is it for
real or is it coming again in a come and
go I think it's going to stay that's
what the trends point to why computer
vision pattern recognition image
processing people should be interested
in compressive sensing sensor and
processing are tightly Club couple it's
not new the early 90s actually there was
a workshop in University of Pennsylvania
called computational sensing regina by G
and Takeo Canada I think R and that even
then there was some interest in bringing
algorithms close to sensors right okay
but now we're able to do it more the I
would claim she and I are is somebody
who has been doing it for a long time
right and and DARPA for many years in
the different Sciences office was
looking at integrated sensing and
processing Denis Healey was the pioneer
for that and then they moved to
something called analog to information a
to I you know don't do the traditional
way can you just grab whatever you need
to do from analog so basically it's
coming from there and there are already
examples of impact compressive sensing
has made in MRI for example the
motivation for compressive sensing came
from MRI world how to reduce the
exposure time okay can we do the same
reconstruction with fewer samples you
know that was the motivation for a
compressive sensing right and we have
done a little bit of work on adding a
little thing to existing SAR sensors so
you can get a similar construction
accuracy with fewer samples and things
like so it's already there is evidence
that this is making an impact and the
early days of vision we all used to
complain you know we don't have enough
data to really show everything you know
it was true those days it was no there
are here and there and suddenly the
cameras showed up all kinds of
showed up and then we started putting
them on moving things platforms robots
vehicles you know unmanned ground
vehicles and aerial vehicles and so
forth Bera is everywhere ok so the
traditional idea of let's collect all
the data in big Giga you know drums and
then we'll take from there and process I
mean we can still do that but if you ask
many folks who are actually looking at
these these data they say we are not
able to do it there are sensors that
produce excessive megabytes megabytes a
pixel in one frame right that's too much
data so the question is is really so
much happening in the in the scene in
the world that we need to have this much
data or can we get to what we need by
doing something more with you know
actually processing the data or before
even it's completely collected right so
one can think of optimized data
acquisition strategies and so forth so
the new thing is that was a - I hear it
is there are two action I mean it's all
the same thing but Derek here simply
means the kind of data we usually
collect and and I think I know the
Alicia's not here in his opening
paragraph a presentation he said math
physics chemistry etc that's one way of
doing it and then the data is the King
and so on I am a traditional person I
don't think this is one versus the other
many physics things happen from
experiments from the understanding lot
of data and refining theory so I think
you know having math and and all these
things there are large data work with
each other is this perfectly reasonable
thing to do so I'm going to just give a
very brief introduction to compressive
sensing and many of you may know all
these things then please you know bear
with me I want to build that because if
I tell you I can do the same with less
data you are instantly going to be
suspicious okay so I have to tell you
why and the what conditions it is
possible right and then present several
examples and I don't have time to talk
about all the examples I'll just
highlight a few but you know assuming
that this is mostly a computer vision
kind of audience and then they'll make
some final points if you look at the
regularization framework in the mid-80s
it was mostly l2 now right you want to
computer optical flow you have the
optical flow constraint equation you
then you have a quadratic minimization
you know the regularization term and
things like that so if you say that l1
is very good you know that's what
Professor strand or shall say oh let's
just replace all yell to with the l1 I
think that's not very interesting in my
view there are some places where that
makes sense so you know we don't want to
start the whole thing again but in many
applications it does make a sense so
when I was a student many outstanding
professor start me at Purdue Kingston
Pugh my advisor the processor cashier
Fukunaga Tom Wang I also came to know as
real Rosenfeld when I was a graduate
student at Purdue so and then I turn
around a series of outstanding students
who taught me and many of them are
listed here and the rich Brainiac is of
course from Rice he built the single
pixel camera which is a practical
example of a compressive sensing system
in operation and Watkins ever was the
student of Jim McClellan spent two years
with me as a postdoc and went to rise
and establish the link between Maryland
rice in terms of compressive sensing
methods so we are producing lot of joint
publications what's the motivation the
first class you take in DSP even at the
undergraduate level they teach you
something known as Nyquist principle
right how fast you have to sample
knowing what the bandwidth is unlike
signal you have right that's a very well
accepted principle where compressed
sensing is says you know you don't have
to really sample at that rate you can do
sub Nyquist rate and then you still will
be able to reconstruct now the question
is is there turning the whole DSP feel
you know on its head I don't think so it
is true only under certain conditions
but to the extent those conditions are
met in practice you gain by doing sub
sampling because you don't have to do
the full sampling things right and so
there are many nice properties and let's
slowly look at them again there's
nothing new Under the Sun as they say
this idea was already there in this 1981
paper came from a pure applications
point of view and you see that the catch
here is a spike train so if there is a
periodic signal like that then you take
the Fourier transform for it it is
already sparse in the frequency domain
and then you want to reconstruct the
original from signal from there that's
the kind of thing they were looking at
it's a very good example very simple but
a very good example so this is a
classical approach you collect data and
then you digitize it and then you do one
of the many orthogonal transforms you
know Fourier being the computationally
the best one DCT is a good approximation
to it sine transform KL transcend
etcetera etcetera and then you look at
the coefficient keep decided to keep a
top few of them you know there are many
ways to decide that and then you code
send and you do the reverse process you
get your original signal back but here
what we are going to assume is that well
let's assume that we still have an end
by one vector X but then only K of the
components are nonzero we know it for
sure then given that what is the
mechanism for producing the original
image okay so that is the one thing and
the next one is are there really signals
such that just the K of them are nonzero
and then everybody else is zero no not
always
many times you have a signal what we
call is a compressible signal they obey
this power law you take the Fourier
transform or wavelet transform any one
of those things the coefficients are
pretty strong at low frequencies and
then they slowly go down so all the
results that are developed for the few
sparse signals where K of the signals
are nonzero are extendable to cases of
compressible signals which are more
practical signals and again here that
the sparsity need not be you know in
just four-year domain sparsity can be in
wavelet domain sparsity can be in many
different domains ok sparsity can be in
spatial domain if you want to develop a
background subtraction method so it's a
very general concept let us look
the high frequency tell me not yet that
is true so you know I will show an
example of how to build dense depth map
from gradient information right so
gradients are sparse and then from there
you can build and so you know that's a
good answer to that question okay so are
there examples of sparse things if you
have a periodic signal its parts in
Fourier domain you have regular images
you know wavelet basis you know produces
its parts and if you have background
subtracted images you know the only few
things are moving the background and so
forth so in a simple mathematical way X
is your original signal and by 1 and K
nonzero entries and stole I actually
have a pointer and then here we have Y
which is kind of there isn't 3 times X P
is the matrix that we will be looking at
but in the next few minutes or so it is
what we call as a fat matrix and then
you have M by 1 measurements ok so k is
this measure of sparsity M is the number
of measurements you have to take n is
the dimension of the original signal
that you would like to reconstruct right
off the bat you know they're going to be
many XS that get mapped on to Y so it's
an ill-posed problem you know in force
problem is something that's very
familiar to computer vision people and
even signal processing people medical
imaging people write image
reconstruction people because we spent a
whole 15 years you know beating that
problem right so all right so that's
mean there's general loss of information
so the question is what kind of fee will
actually allow for you to reconstruct X
from Y you know that is the question
that's the question that mathematicians
answered they said well for a fee to do
that it's supposed to satisfy what is
known as a restricted isometry property
and well you know this is soon after
lunch and the lunch was pretty heavy
though I mean it's like going to a
wedding or something like that all that
was missing was a band okay so this is a
nice proof and tower's the field
medalist so you know these guys right
some serious stuff ok so I will
recommend you to read this but basically
all it means is that it's a all subsets
of K columns taken
from Tara are nearly orthogonal to okay
I'm sorry this should be feet but you
know I just you stay at this light for
some reason okay now that is a difficult
problem to check because then you know K
of n it can take for awhile depending on
the dimensions and so forth so these
mathematicians realized why they have
you put where you have to put others in
distress
so they came up with at least three
matrices that satisfy this property one
is the fee is made of Bernoulli you know
plus one minus one random matrix other
possibilities fee is made of Gaussian
entries again a random matrix or it
could be a partial Fourier basis so
these are the three matrices that are
guaranteed to satisfy this property so
if Y which is the compressive
measurement is three times X X as the
original signal where fee is one of
these matrices there is a there are
methods available which will give you X
given Y now the assumption here is that
in actual application you have Y with
you
not X because if you already have X you
have already got the data the horse is
out the outside the barn already okay so
if we have Y and if you know there is
parsecity in the underlying signal X and
then if the way Y was collected there
was this random coding fee okay then you
have algorithms available L not l1 tons
of algorithms you know they are
available okay so that is the thing now
yesterday I gave a longer talk a triple
ID you know in comparison you can assert
and rightly asked the question so don't
you think it is a restriction that only
these three matrices that we know of
true but then I talked gave him an
example you do kernel SVM how many
different kernels that books talk about
three right there is a polynomial kernel
there is a sigmoid kernel there is a
radial basis function kernel everybody
any book that talks about SVM karna
these are the only three things that are
mentioned or the last ten years and
everybody seems to be happy so my
response to him was that well you know
see what you can do with these three
looks like these three are good enough
right now but maybe you should start
thinking of other piece that can satisfy
this property then you will become very
famous
so that was the professorial answer
saying that I don't know but those are
only three things that are there okay
now I talked about signals that are
really sparse in the sense there's n by
one and K of them are nonzero but in
reality it's not so you basically have a
signal that is represented in terms of
our normal basis so you can write the
original signal in terms of the
coefficients these coefficients could be
a wavelet coefficients could be
four-year coefficients discrete
coefficients depending on what the
underlying fees are and so you write it
in this way and then when you have your
original data as CX and you have
compressive measurement Y as a random
matrix multiplied by X and then it goes
through here are the same problem here
right given Y now compute what s s s is
now supposed to be sparse so this takes
care of the situation where the signal
is compressible and and so on okay so
this is a very nice picture and folks at
Rice University have t-shirts like them
if you want one if you really believe in
compressive sensing you can send some
money I'm sure they'll give you a
t-shirt in different colors and so on
and what what yeah but it's a reasonable
price yeah so yeah why you have the
random matrix and this is a wavelet
basis this is the sparse signal
coefficient one two three four
components and basically the four
columns of this combined matrix you know
come into play and so forth okay so this
is extending it from purely sparse
signals to this guy okay again the
question is how many such measurements
you should have right we have three
things here we have n is our original
dimension K is the number of nonzero
entries M is the number of measurements
I should make and then there is this
bound that is given of course in the you
know you like to have this theoretical
thing but then you can get a little bit
more you can get ten percent more and so
forth well I'll tell you later on why
when you do that you are in better shape
okay so more and more people are saying
let's not be so stingy you know if you
can add another you know ten percent of
this data you would do much better off
okay so what are the things you
- do you have to figure out in which
basis is the signal sparse if you choose
the right basis where the signal is
exactly sparse that's beautiful but
sometimes we don't know so what we do is
we just go with the wave left and it is
not an accident that many of the leading
researchers in compressed sensing
they're also leading researchers in
wavelets you know Donohue and others
right so if in fact the one of the
algorithms matching pursuit algorithm
that was done by Steve Malaya 1990 he's
a very big guy in wavelets okay so I
recommend his new book the wavelet
guided tour of wavelets a new addition
the last few chapters have some very
nice exposition of sparsity compressive
sensing and so forth okay so all right
if you want to do this reconstruction
okay so what I would like to do is I
would like to get the constraint get me
this parses to signal X given that Y
should be equal to VX I know why I know
fee so give me this parses X right so
that is the optimization problems almost
like you know give me the the
derivatives of a surface P you know Z of
X Y the derivatives are P of n Q and
shape from shading you have Y of X Y or
I of X Y is R of P Q R is a nonlinear
reflectance function give me a B and Q
so that the difference between them is
minimized in some norm and subject to
some smoothness criterion so that it is
regularized okay same framework so that
means you can think of a l2 as the
easiest thing to do because electrical
engineers like the l2 because when you
do least squares you have a closed form
expression and everybody is happy okay
somehow we never really worried that
much about l1 and other things but so l2
is is good but for this particular
problem you know l2 is not very good you
know it does not find a spot solution
the best approach is L not because it
actually you know looks at the number of
nonzero elements and it can do it well
but then there is something known as the
NP something whatever whenever you see
NP it's is you want to stay away from it
all right yeah even if you are a
computer if you're a pure computer
scientist you want to kind of into it
because you can come up with
approximations and so on otherwise you
want to move away from it so l1 norm is
reasonable to do
so instead of L 2 or L naught you now
minimize the L 1 norm okay all right now
the question is then there is a lot of
things like you know reducing to linear
programming and so on and again it's a
MATLAB team you know these days things
that get into MATLAB become very popular
okay so I'm not trying to sell MATLAB
but because students are under stress
immense stress of trying things writing
C program and decoding it they just put
together some MATLAB and this and then
towards the end we tell them can you
please make a C code because somebody
wants it then they start all over again
so but that's the way it works out okay
this is a very quick summary of the
different possibilities and this all the
references I have given so you will be
able to go and read ok so as long as
there is this parsecity K and you have
enough measurements so you should be
able to do it ok then the question is
all right
you tell me that L naught is the right
thing to do then it is hard and then you
say go and do l1 under what conditions
in L naught and l1 are equal again
doneger has an answer to that in this
question
he basically draws something known as a
phase transition diagram which is a
measure of under sampling which is a
measure of sparsity and then this curve
looks somewhat like this my powerpoint
skills are at 101 level I tried to take
that picture from one of the papers and
paste it on my thing it didn't come out
well so I got to give that task to one
of my students that nasty thing about
being a professor it's a skill skilling
job the longer you are the more you
depend on your students thank God tenure
so the point here is in that curve okay
if below the curve L not in L word when
we're not fine if you're above the curve
you gotta do L not to be better but
that's not the the final solution you
can actually adjust the sampling rate
you can collect more and then go below
the curve so the message is L not is is
a perfect one but you know none of us is
perfect so let's not bother to do the
perfect one and especially when it is
very very difficult to do do l1 things
are available is much well studied and
so forth so
there is a series of these kinds of
algorithms that have been developed
I mentioned Steve malas matching pursued
in the context of a building a
dictionary for wavelet based analysis
and then one of my colleagues professor
Krishna Prasad and his student party
they developed some Pinos orthogonal
matching pursue okay and then there is a
simultaneous orthogonal matching pursuit
then there is Co Sam as you know in some
of these fields the more abbreviations
you are in command of the more you know
Thorat ativ you are so you should be
able to rattle the MPO MP some Co samp
and so on and in your talks and then
make sure you know what they are and
things like that yeah so anyway what I'm
saying is is as large history see for
example party o MP mullet and so on this
was rediscovered in 2007 they were not
aware of this work has disappeared in a
little-known conference known as
Allerton conference yesterday hundred
miles not that we're ominous you know in
Pacific Grove and yeah so you know
that's not very well and also this one
for those of you who looking for some
software to play with Rice University if
you go and say compressive sensing rich
Bernie has done a wonderful job of
putting everything together all the key
papers and presentations and software
and so on okay so you will really very
quickly come to speed with this idea
okay now okay this is again saying well
the same kind of problem suppose instead
of subject to this just Y is V X it's
called bases pursuit if you have also
noise because we deal with noisy sensors
and if you know that Y minus px l2 norm
should be less than this then it is
called a basis for should be noising so
you will see these things mentioned a
lot in this literature okay the recent
developments in computer vision and
graphics I'm not going to say much about
graphics you know I have not done much
although some of my students are doing
lot of work on that from Merl there Amit
Agarwal Ashok with argon they all had
three or four SIGGRAPH papers every year
and so you know if your student is
working in a field you should not work
in the same
if you do it's like eating out of their
plate so I said graphics they are doing
well so why should I bother about them
thank you please erase that again I
thought you were just going to nonverbal
communication with me what happened all
right this is a example single pixel
camera it's built in rice and I'll
briefly show you how it looks
mmm if you want to if you go to Best Buy
and ask for a single pixel camera
they'll say sir it's you have to
backorder and it will take many years
for you to get it so don't do that it's
not there yet and then there is this
work that my student students Virago in
and ready that pammi they report that
and no I you can take a look at it it's
a very interesting problem they have
this low speed in a videos of rotating
mill and so on Merl is the thing that's
owned by mitsubishi right so they do
real industrial things and so from that
low speed camera they are able to build
instead of using a high-speed camera
which will be very expensive
from there they have built a video they
are able to reconstruct a video that
gives you the high speed video for that
right because of the perfectly periodic
motion so the Fourier transform are
spikes so there is parts it's very
beautiful done so please read that tiny
paper and look at the supplementary
video tapes for that ok and then I will
give all these things as you can see
there are many things coming up and this
is a very nice paper this is from Ravi
Rommel T's group and it appeared first
in ECC V 2008 and now it's this classic
straightforward applications of
compressive sensing for estimating brdf
so you do the compressive sensing theory
and say where is the application for it
that reads that paper perfect match okay
so that that's why it's a nice thing to
look at I'm going to yes parts
representations so you you can now use
the compressive sensing kinds of ideas
for building sparse representations I
will tell you if you give me a 10
minutes I'm going to talk about that
this is basically the work from EEMA and
john wright and so on sparse
representations for face recognition
right this right yes so okay so I it's
kind of a you you may look like it's
artificially created sparseness but but
it has some advantages now okay so this
is the single pixel camera it's called
SPC and the idea here is you have the
image and then this is their end random
matrix it is made of digital micro
mirrors this mirrors you know will have
a binary thing no one if it is looking
at the lens that is collecting all that
data if it is looking away it produces
zero and you have a way of controlling
this configuration so it's like a binary
spin model I know I've seen
configuration okay so these guys come
they get messed up by that they get
collected you produce one such
measurement and then as many
measurements as you want you will create
different random configurations okay
and I only wanted to show this I didn't
want to show the other three slides that
that come after this because this is
done on an optical cable with lens and
mirrors and so forth right now so okay
so it's not ready yet for although I
hear that somebody is trying to build
this okay and they show the examples of
how you can construct the reconstructed
image this is the thing and if you only
take 16 percent measurements how it
looks and so forth so this and there is
also another example the rich has in
soccer ball and so on so if you ask the
question is there an espy see the answer
is yes where is it it is in rice but
there are other variations of cameras
Hardware mostly done
Admiral that kind of uses this principle
yeah what they are saying is if this is
the 16% yeah yeah yeah yeah this is the
fee this is remember I said the the
matrix y is equal to Phi X Woofie can be
a Bernoulli matrix we can be Gaussian
matrix at a four-year basis and so on so
this is the zero one thing the mirrors
you know you can so that it'll comes and
gets reflected or it won't go there so 1
0 there is a it produces 0 array of 1 0
micro mirror
output is it collects our of them there
is a lens here I don't know if you can
see it there is a lens it focuses and
produces one value okay and then that
you do ad that creates is one component
of why it can be done very quickly
that's what they're saying the benefit
is that they're actually getting
directly why they are not scanning that
you're getting this right they're just
getting white and from that why they'll
give you a very very good approximation
of it not necessarily this is just the
first implementation yeah
first implementation right in fact what
show can do they'll have multiple layers
of these things and so they can
simultaneously produce yes yes yes yes
yes in fact the work that you will see
the remember I showed you the rotation
of the milling tool that that is
actually moving right you can take 30
frames per second video of that and
construct a video as though you have
2,000 frames per second camera at a very
very reasonable price there is such a
real camera is probably I using this
principle it's a penny paper I can
towards the end the reason I'm not
showing that is that I downloaded the
wrong videos and so I am maybe I won't
confuse you with that so but penny
supplementary material has that or I can
put you in touch with them yeah go ahead
yes yes
no here you can assume it's a real image
so in a wavelet basis you do spots no no
no because it's all using optimization
algorithms right okay now yeah yeah but
we're not talking about compression what
we are saying is given the sparse why
you know that's okay how much yeah well
it depends on how sparse the original
signal is there are I don't think we
should see this as a way of replacing
JPEG or impact like that there are
special cases where you can change the
way you collect the signature by using
the coded aperture imaging and so on and
if the underlying phenomena actually is
a very sparse signal then you can
exploit that if you didn't know it you
are going to go through the traditional
way of collecting that's right
dancing yes that that's possible
yeah but I can show you some example
later on inside imaging and and so on
where we are showing with a significant
reduction in the acquisition things we
get similar reconstruction so it depends
on the and the problem and and also
there are things like you know going
from sparse gradients okay there's a
little conference yeah okay that's
alright
okay the idea of building things from
gradients is now gaining some attention
because you know if you have whether you
believe shape from shading or not if
there is some way you can get P and Q
you can put together in a nice way and
get your depth map right that is the
thing but thought horn wrote a nice
paper called height and shape from
shading right where once you have P and
Q could be from photometric stereo could
be from shape from shading and given
that then you have to do something known
as integrability and when you integrate
the derivatives and produce the Z's the
more people are very excited about how
to use the gradient they've actually
built a so called gradient camera that
means it responds only for you know
derivatives in the image in some sense
right now these gradients are spots they
are not they're everywhere in the image
and so given those gradients how you can
reconstruct and that is something that
we looked at in a cvpr 2009 paper and
well one of the things that you have to
do when you make your Z map from the
gradients is that satisfy that the
second partials dou squared Z by dou X
dou Y should be equal to dou square Z
dou by dou X so that means you know the
closed contour it should be zero and
that can be equally interpreted as this
criterion you know the curl is zero
right so you can now assuming that you
estimate your gradients
okay so you can write this as a
reconstruction problem okay G is your s
is the surface you are trying to
estimate these the gradients G is the
gradients and and given and then you can
pre multiply both by C and create D as c
and c g and
okay so you can now figure out what the
errors in the gradients that you have by
minimizing the l1 nom and once you can
figure out where the errors are you can
smooth it out and do a surface
reconstruction now the thing is here
where is the sparse recovery coming into
play well one of the Criterion's is we
would like to minimize the the sparse
error vector subject to the condition
that D is equal to Z okay so this is in
a classical compressive sensing
framework and if you don't want to do it
in the l-not form then you can do it in
the l1 form okay so what this basically
allows you to do is build surface Z of X
Y from gradients using sparsity as the
criterion so here we use the l1 norm
instead of the traditional l2 now now
when we talked about the compressive
sensing we said the matrix P has to have
a specific structure now that specific
structure is defined as you get your
compressive measurements why is P equal
to X now in this formulation I don't
have that luxury I am trying to get a
sparse estimate of the error subject to
the condition D is equal to C e see here
is basically your matrix that links the
derivative and the surface
darah C is not random C is a
deterministic one C comes from your
problem so the question is how can you
guarantee that you can do the
reconstruction well we have shown in our
paper in cvpr 2009 a detailed analysis
and reward configurations of error
distributions will this C satisfy the
r.i.p property okay so you can apply
this parts idea to all regularization
problems fine but the matrix that is
equivalent to feed that's going to
appear there there is no guarantee it is
going to satisfy the IRAP property so
you will not be able to convince people
that you are actually recovering what
you are supposed to recover so that is
the difference when you go from the
traditional signal processing
compressive sensing ideas and then you
have to go and try to apply it for other
domains
because the matrix that you get there
you get there because of the problem
right you can't randomize how the
surface derivatives will make up the
surface you're going to get garbage we
can randomize it you can analyze
anything so so so these are the
interesting twists that you can you know
see when you go from you know signal
processing to computer vision right so
anyway you can do the l1 minimization
and this is a classic Mossad image that
if you do the least squares all kinds of
crazy things happen and if you do the l1
norm of course professor Stan washer
always says he doesn't care whether
there is our IP or not he's going to do
l1 anyway and then there are because
there are some very beautiful iterative
equation solutions are available for l1
optimization he's very very excited
about something as Berkman iterations
okay so if you hear that somewhere you
know that's what it is l1 optimization
method yes right yes because we were
doing from sparse gradients they don't
have the full thing that's why and we
can do similar things through motion
fields to death and so on yes it is okay
all right
so yes yeah l1 not l1 now yeah so l1
because when you get your P and Q from
any method there are going to be a lot
of kinds of errors outliers as well as
so it is somewhat related to outlier
issue but it's a better solution is even
there you know you still have this
reader sending functions and so on which
are kind of variations or the underlying
square law functions right that is true
no l1 gives you know it's still convex
optimization problem so if the
algorithms are there and the only
problem with applying compressing the
ideas division is that the matrix that
you have to deal with may not be a
random matrix almost always it will not
be around a matrix so the burden is on
you that l1 reconstruction follows the
guarantees of our IP and teeka
yes that's true yeah but you know you
know the way we go from gradients to Z
of X Y in the regular you know franca
xalapa thing that is the l2 norm - right
we all know that you have those
situations not peculiar to this right
all I'm saying is instead of doing l2
you do l1 but then the problem if you
are able to analyze the underlying
matrices and guarantee that it obeys the
principles of construction as dictated
by compression saying I think it's a
nice thing because we always do del -
okay so kinda yeah that'll be
interesting to try yes okay so we did
this right and then one of my students
got in touch with you know Anna Gilbert
is a very big name in compressed sensing
she's a mathematician has been some
wonderful work and then she has worked
on these kinds of problems of building
from MRI images from gradients and the
criterion is that the total variation
they call it which is basically square
root of sum of squares of the
derivatives and then that should be the
the number of nonzero components is K
and then try to solve the problem in
this way this is the formulation so
minimize the L naught nom subject to the
fact that Y is the Fourier partial
Fourier basis is used here you know so Y
W Sigma here is a career thing and of
course then we know we don't like L
naught and she does the L 1 and so forth
and there are theoretical guarantees are
IP and incoherence and so on so the idea
here is this is what they did and they
went and optimized this problem as you
can see total variation as the l1 norm
and the and the condition under which it
has to be reconstructed my student came
in contact with this paper and then
looked at the paper and then
surprisingly the kind of equations that
were there they're very very close to
Frank our chilapa algorithm which from
1988 remember that - from P and Q you
had a Fourier basis I don't know how
many of you saw this okay so Fourier
basis and people did cosine bases
wavelets and so
so the idea here was producing
integrable surface from P and Q using a
projection onto Conway except set idea
right so once he saw these links he told
them hey guys we do best better than the
Franklin xalapa thing because now you
know you can do Python solvers 1990 I
had a paper and penny
where I showed many of these problems
can be it you know solve using direct
analytical methods the Python solvers
people kind of you know it was it
disappeared for a while and now this
Python thing you keep hearing it again
so anyway so we reformulated the problem
and since they were doing it using the
total variation approach we told them
well you can actually try to reconstruct
the derivative along the x-axis y-axis
independently using the Elwin
optimization problem here right minimize
P prime 1 and subject to the fact that
you have the partial for your
information and reduce the l2 norm so
this becomes the basis pursuit denoising
problem for reconstructing the
derivative with respect to X with
respect to Y given these two things then
you do the integrated gradient using
Poisson solvers so this is a very rare
case when some algorithm that was done
in medical imaging and they had no I you
know think of what's being done in
computer vision and then we kind of
lucked into so we could improve on their
algorithms for example here is the MRI Y
12 by 512 and then B is not good 0
filling I don't think you should do that
and then the gradient OMP orthogonal
matching pursuit total variation method
then this is the method where we do the
P and Q reconstruction using l1
optimization like a compressive sense
and reconstruction algorithm and then
use the Poisson solver for linking them
together and produce what the underlying
image should be so this is with the nine
68.5 random andr sampling and things
like that ok so and then if you have
noise then you have to do BPD and with
the 65% so here is an example as I said
the whole momentum for comparison thing
came from reducing the exposure time in
real scanning applications okay so if
you can reduce by one-third and get the
same kind of
instruction it is a good thing to do
okay now coming to present neva tears
question right from 2008
I think Berkeley and University of
Illinois they got joined together
EEMA John Wright Allen yang and Shankar
Shastri and so on they they were looking
at this method what is the thing suppose
I take all your faces put it in my bag
and then again I see one of you in the
same acquisition condition same pose
sames skeptical expression that ROM has
now just kidding okay all right then
what I do is I put this no face from ROM
as a linear combination of all the faces
here to the extent ROM space has not
changed in illumination force expression
the coefficients corresponding to just
him will be nonzero everything else will
be zero so what do you have here you
have a sparse vector you have a sparse
vector so that's their idea course in a
traditional pattern recognition we never
say that the testing sample is going to
be a linear combination of training
samples it doesn't happen that way
phases are acquired in different poses
different expressions occlusions
different illumination condition but
let's forget all of them let us assume
it's a very ideal situation okay so that
is where the sparse thing is being done
here okay
now and then you you have to estimate
alpha alpha here is a coefficient just
corresponding to and then you can
reconstruct the image once you have that
alpha and then you know you can do a
recognition based on that so this kind
of motivates as to also look into what
is known as dictionary based method for
face recognition what I would consider
the work from Illinois and Berkeley as
simple dictionary where all they have is
one or more samples of your face and
they hope that the new face that they
have is somehow linear combination of
this okay that's a very you know
restrictive assumption suppose if you
are able to have a dictionary that has
all of your faces and all poses in all
illumination all expressions
and then if you have a way of
constructing a sparse dictionary somehow
then this becomes interesting okay
that's the approach and here in the
dictionary method what we show is a
training image and then there are
methods like method of optimal
directions K SVD
which is somewhat like a generalization
of k-means algorithm from Alfred Brooks
and others you learn the dictionary and
then this dictionaries could be anything
now and in the traditional way of Steve
mellitus wavelets dictionaries right or
wavelet packets and so forth
now you can actually put faces under
different expressions parts of faces
iris and what have you and then you
project these guys on to the dictionary
elements and then construct the Ricans
know reconstruction error and then you
can do that so this is a big explanation
of K SVD and it's actually a very nice
piece of work from Aaron at all so
that's what we used and it's it's a kind
of a recursive way of updating the
dictionary components somewhat very
similar to k-means algorithm okay but
then it you know it enforces the
sparsity crichton as you can see here
tau you know is the eigen vectors
columns of tau are eigen vectors and you
want the components of eigen vectors to
be sparse you specify how sparse you
want and so forth so there is an idea of
building a sparse dictionary for faces
so that is where the compressive sensing
ideas are useful and if you want to fool
the system with an image you know it
will not be very flattering if you give
this image and somebody from the
dictionary of faces is chosen but
luckily it doesn't happen because the
reconstruction error is you know so high
you can immediately say no this is not a
face okay all right
now the question is this is fine in a
traditional signal processing way this
is fine but in computer vision it's not
fine because we never see the object in
the same light in the same view so how
do you now account for those problems so
one thing we could do was do the
relighting kinds of things just to
handle the illumination issue for
example you know Creek Minh and is
associate short that if you give a pace
that is eliminated using an arbitrary
source of light you can almost
reconstruct the same by using nine
points of light that's what they talked
about
their work and they'll tell you exactly
where these point sources should be you
know in terms of their tilt angles and
so on so you can actually build your
dictionary using these real lighting
conditions the analogy I like to give is
that now when you look at a dictionary
right you have a word you have a core
word and then they tell you what are the
possible variations of that they don't
have to necessarily put every possible
variation of a word to have a huge
dictionary right so here we have the the
core word here is a frontal well
illuminated face you know and so on and
then you have variations illumination
variation is one and so forth but if you
don't use farce considerations your
dictionary is going to be unmanageable I
mean you have to okay you have to do all
these standard things with Al and things
like video to beat them now we didn't
start with phase we did we want to do
iris because we have a project with Navy
for a coast guards to jump onto a ship
and get the iris signature and things
like that so we thought we will do it so
we looked at the method response and so
on and we had a fellow from IBM dr.
Nellie data came and told about how they
secured their biometrics there is this
concept of cancelable biometrics suppose
somebody walks away with your biometrics
template you know how do you manage that
the point here is that they said oh we
use random projections so we take the
you know features for iris we do random
projections and we send it out and then
you can still compare using those and
just if somebody walks away with that
that's fine they cannot conflict your
original image unless they had the FIH
matrix okay when you do random
projections you want to get your
original eye these features back you
need to have the P matrix so that you
can do the elbow and optimization and so
on so you keep your fee matrix in a
different place and then if somebody
calls and says oh
somebody took my iris biometric you just
do a different fee matrix and send it
away you don't have to create a new iris
for the person so then suddenly it
clicked to us we talked about random
projections and compresses sensing they
talked about under projections insecure
things so we put it together and
produced a nice iris system and of
course there is a little bit of
mathematics here called JL EMA and so on
which says that is a reasonable thing to
do because a mapping that sat is kind of
preserves the distances
in the original space as well as the
random projections you know the
transformation space is a random
projection matrix so this is going to be
a family paper of course when you do the
random projections you have to still
convinced that the percentage of
recognition
that's not degree so I'm going to very
quickly IFS compressive sensing is
critical for still images big still
images it's even more critical for video
frames so you know there is this big
deal about dynamic texture models that
people talk about so we have developed a
method for estimating the parameters or
the dynamic texture model given random
projections and how it can be used for
video classification and so on I there
is a EC CV 2010 paper on that so I'm not
going to mention so we are also looking
at how to do good image alignment using
this these are some of the things I did
not mention and there was this question
about whether you can really beat a
compression thing well I don't know if I
have a direct answer to it but given the
fact all the current compressive sensing
people are former compression people I
am hoping that they would not have made
that direction if they didn't think that
was fruitful that's how I'm just going
to leave it at that
no no remember we had this question
whether it's going to be the compression
or I'm going to say it's all the current
compressive sensing people are formerly
wavelet compression people so I hope
they moved in the right direction
which is not bad or will you want to
actually write okay okay no Richard ie
yeah okay yeah no okay we can do the
same recognition with much fewer things
that blacks what that's what we have
Shane right yeah no I never worked in
compression look at this one right I'm
able to reconstruct a video sequence
using a random projections and so on and
you know I'm getting the same so I can
actually do the same video analysis
using random projections rather than the
original measurements and I have even
shown how we can do video video
classification using random projections
and then performance is pretty good okay
and we are doing image alignment for
image is collected by UAV and you know
we use sometimes we do random projection
sometimes we don't but there is
considerable saving in terms of how much
you have to really sense okay but this
one I have I don't think I have that
information here but I can show for this
particular not this one okay here there
is precise yeah yeah okay now as far as
a real example we have a compressive
sorry imaging system people are
interested in building it there is
clearly I removed it because I didn't
think SAR was the right thing for this
audience but I can send you their paper
you can take a look at it let me just
quickly come minutes it's good to be
skeptical I'm not selling compressor
sensing you know I'm not building the
cameras but I have many examples with my
students at Merle where they are
starting with sparse representations
actually showing results the example of
you know the milling machine thing is
there it's real you can look at it in
pammi example of from the gradient
cameras building depth map that's a good
example the Amara example I showed is
good and rich and I are in a five-year
project we are looking at opportunistic
sensing for army so it clearly looks
like it's promising but you know it's
good to be skeptical right all right so
that's why
saying cannot and will not solve all
computer vision problems right now may
provide better solutions in many cases
renewed interest in Elwin methods and
these are they thinks the the point is
algorithm people have to now know little
bit about hardware I think to me that
itself is a good thing
otherwise we wait for those guys to
collect data and then we complain data
is not good and we can't solve it and so
forth now they tell you why don't you
just build a down camera yourself and do
what you want to do so that I think is a
positive thing for computer vision image
understanding and I say ask if you can
do without CS before this is a little
bit of a variation of John F Kennedy
sorts of things okay it's the right way
University website but you know at least
once in five years we need to have
something new I always watch the point
in being this is business right you want
to build products you don't want you
want stability you want one thing that
works so you can build it can sell but
if you are not in the business of
building anything I think this is a good
thing to do you will have fun at least
okay thank you any questions I'd be
happy to answer you start up by 5:00 in
the morning
it's kind of barely sunny everything
starts out slow and you build up your
day by about nine o'clock you're busy
running at 10 o clock
it's almost and so after about the first
20 minutes it is 10 o'clock
anyway
oh well that's not I don't think that's
our problem has it ever been our problem
yeah so it no no no listen no no let's
hear yeah but I think we should not just
dismiss something saying you know I have
to really do that right so that's all I
think it's happening I know
Merlin's very well guy no they what they
are doing and my students are there it's
very exciting
let me put it that you know we live in a
day where okay you know Anand and you
are getting it's not 66 anymore if you
are getting 96 megabyte separate after
frame at video rates it's just too much
you can't do anything so you have to ask
the question how do we affect you any
Cenobite no no not that's not this is
happening through Wow
whatever whatever
yeah exposure next for sure okay
exposure exposure we want to reconstruct
so that the sparsity thing is respected
I didn't say that that somebody said
yeah it's compression can do better than
this
I said I don't know but this this tells
me of no designs for building a camera I
think that's exciting I don't build
cameras but my students are building all
kinds of cool gadgets at mer and I know
I'm aware of them so it's a good thing
to do as a PhD student this is a good
thing to look at
oh yeah yeah my good friend and Duke
caliber and he actually has a whole
theory based on deterministic he doesn't
care but you know that's true but I like
random things so I know of his work we
actually want to compare with this then
I said now why I think random looks good
yeah that I does he know did you tell
him that
called a blank different scheme okay
yeah okay are you familiar with Carter
Bronxville yeah
right right okay so yeah I mean some
people like diet coke some like Diet
Sprite you know but but I I agree with
you we want to try that we want because
sometimes this idea
yeah yeah right right right yeah I agree
oh it's a DSP to 300 400 or no no okay
yes yes yes yes yes the base is very do
sparse then you got it right for
background subtraction its space BAE
it's sparse in the spatial domain
inordinate ardently okay yeah to think
better in terms of actually sensing the
whys directly using see they're also you
have an analog X and then you are
digitizing it and you are proving that
you are able to reconstruct let's have
you justify all of that but here we are
directly going to Y and we want to get
the good big X so it's a little
different it's not the same thing but I
can talk to you more about that yeah for
occlusion the work the this parts method
that I talked about from right and so on
surprisingly it works great for
occlusions when you have you know big
chunks of the face missing and that's
why we were interested in there for iris
as you know iris is so control and
anytime you you do this or your eyelids
kind of close and you miss part of the
signature the numbers are going down so
we used it and we are able to get good
results for iris that's the reason for
occlusion but you still have you know
face recognition is really open-ended
problem yes yes yes yes yes it did the
impact they claim excellent results for
the elbe that i said which is considered
to be a tough thing and so we kind of
try to improve on there
surveillance situation someone is
dropping a small thumb-sized bombs very
sharp very quickly I don't know I have
to think about that yeah noisy
observations no no basis pursued a nice
thing is noisy right you there for
example in my reconstruction from P and
Q I have a GSD S Plus ëthat is noise so
we do yeah you know we have to that's
right yeah yeah you know all the
algorithms have all algorithms have one
little bit of a magic syrup that you got
to put into it
right so yeah you know so even in a
simple carbon filter you gotta adjust
sometimes the variances of the
measurement system versus the
observation system you know that so
that's not talked about in public it is
that it is that good so huh oh blog okay
yeah
for a compressive sensing oh yeah yeah
okay okay that's good the impulse very
true because you know we had surgery
over the right information theories why
are they interested I mean he came and
gave a talk and anytime you have this
impulse and then your the thing this is
the sparse right just to catch that I
agree I agree
in fact you to pick up the specular
components you know from images this is
very useful for that so listen we don't
like compressive sensing that's alright
do it the usually way it's okay I'm not
offended